most people are angry like Jeffrey Marsh
Jeffrey Marsh who is this
super like the creepiest guy you ever
saw out of the weirdest horror movie
ever
promoter of transgenderism
he like cast out of Central Casting to
be the Uber villain of transgenderism
Jeffrey Marsh
is
angry with his critics it's okay to be
angry
anger is often your body your mind your
Soul's way of telling you that you are
worth something
that other people are worth something
that Justice counts
for something
so no don't be afraid
don't be um
don't be afraid to show your anger
don't be afraid
it puts the lotion on its skin or else
it gets the hose again speaking of
transgender representation in cinema and
popular culture
what what of his point
his point is anger is really good
you should be angry use that anger
channel that anger Libs say this all the
time channel that anger take that you
don't usually hear a conservative say
this
because anger
999 times out of a thousand is going to
lead you in the wrong direction
Drew has this line he says anger is the
devil's cocaine
I'm not saying there is no place for
righteous anger
they're as far a far greater place for
righteousness broadly
yes there can be a case for righteous
anger but most of the time that you are
getting angry you are falling into a
Temptation and you're falling into the
sin of Wrath and it's going to lead you
astray and you're going to feel
justified in doing it because your
enemies might really be as bad as you
think they are and the way that they
persecute you might really be as bad as
you think it is
but you are called to patience
you were called not to indulge in Wrath
that it's like when you punish a child
if you want to punish your child or
spank your child or anything like that
what do they always tell you I'm such a
softie with my kids I gotta I gotta get
I gotta get tougher before I totally
spoil my kids but what do the people
what do the the Educators always tell
you
what are the what does your grandma
always tell you well you don't don't
punish a child when you're angry
wait until you've calmed down if you're
dealing with a rogue employee like I'm
dealing with Mr Davies all the time you
know gallivanting around carousing doing
all sorts of nonsense when I'm going to
you know bring down the hammer you don't
do it when you're angry you because
you're you're going to lose your your
rational faculties you're going to lose
control for how many decades now have we
heard we need to end colonialism in
Africa
we need to end neo-colonialism in Africa
we colonialism was the worst thing that
ever happened and we need to let the
African nations govern themselves
Okay so we've started doing that now
we're letting the African nations govern
themselves
are the Liberals happy about that I
don't think so there's a headline here
from the guardian
Ugandan MPS pass Bill imposing death
penalty for homosexuality
that's African countries governing
themselves
to you and it's kind of funny that it's
the liberals who are the ones who say
this is outrageous America so terrible
stop spreading your evil ideas please
ugandans live as you like
very good we are going to kill all of
the homosexuals
not like that
um did you what so it's like that
wonderful video from the from the
African newscast you are gay why are you
gay the Liberals don't they can't
understand that because in their View
every single culture is liberal and
liberal in a 2023 kind of liberal way
every all the cultures are just the same
the only difference is some people have
more money and some people have less
money and some people get a little more
Sunshine some people get a little more
fog but you know we all basically agree
on everything that's not true
so the Liberals paradoxically are the
most inclined to impose their values on
the world but one of those values is not
imposing your values on the world so how
does one make sense of that the way
they're going to make sense of that is
they're probably going to go in and
reimpose their values
now for as far as I'm concerned the
death penalty is a little a little harsh
all right I'm all for standards and sort
of maintaining certain behaviors in the
Public Square but death penalty seems a
little strong but but if Uganda is going
to have self-determination this is what
they're going to do and there are
certain areas where African nations are
doing this
where I think a lot of American
conservatives would say hey African
nations can you come Run for the
legislature over here the libs are
constantly trying to push abortion on
Africa Africa says we don't want
abortion the libs are constantly trying
to push contraception on Africa the
Africans are saying we don't want
contraception we don't
we don't want that imposition that's the
imposition of your culture westerners
you think the imposition of your culture
is I don't know capitalism and racism
and this is now every country on earth
is extremely racist other than the West
okay that's you're not exporting racism
or anything like that what you're
exporting is the LGBT flag and condoms
and abortion and all the trappings of
liberalism
it's the new kind of colonial when the
libs protest colonialism you better
bring those protest signs and take a
look in the mirror speaking of cultural
differences
a Michigan College
has just announced a number of new
graduation ceremonies
this is Grand Valley State University
the Multicultural Affairs office over at
Grand Valley State has now announced
there will be graduation ceremonies or
celebrations
for black students
is the black graduation
Asian students
latinx students
talk about colonialism and
cultural uh overriding of of norms and
tradition latinx students
Native American students
lgbtqia plus students there's one group
of students I can't it's actually a
couple but I can't quote find on this
list
Where is the
where's the white student graduation are
the Multicultural Affairs officers said
that won't exist
and there's no where's the
I don't know the Christian or let's say
just broadly religious
student graduation maybe to counter the
more novel
uh sexual Revolution graduation no none
of that's there and
the response of many conservatives is
this is not going to go on forever
at a certain point white people are
going to get extremely angry about this
and they're going to push back and say
no you can't just you can't make US
second-class citizens we're not going to
tolerate that but I'm not I'm actually
not totally convinced I think the libs
probably will get away with it at least
for a very long time and they'll do that
because white people don't have a racial
consciousness
and it's one of the delightful things
about white people is we just don't
think about race that much we think that
race is
a relatively unimportant aspect of our
identity
you think about religion a lot we think
about culture a lot we think about
Nation we think about Affinity to
different
I don't know hobbies and vocations we
don't race is really really low on the
list
but for every other racial group in the
world it's much higher according to Pew
white racial Consciousness is 15 for
Asians Hispanics and blacks it's over 50
percent for all of them and for black
people it's over 70 percent
so as long as that persists then you're
going to get you're going to get more of
these
sorts of graduation ceremonies
though there is there is a kind of
subtle
there is a a subtly Colonial or racist
undertone to this whole thing which is
oh there's the Latino graduation there's
the gay graduation there's the black
graduation
but the main graduation that's the white
graduation there is it's I don't think
the limbs are totally conscious of it
but it's it's the the same accident of
their uh invectives against colonialism
and racism that you see in their Affairs
in Africa today's fake headline Friday
I've got more mailbag questions to get
to we will get to that you will help me
to pick the correct
or the fake headline rather out of the
five that Mr Davies is trying to stump
me on the only way to do it is to become
a member of the creme de La Creme not
here on YouTube just like a leech
sucking up all this free content without
parting with your hard-earned money so
that you can help me figure out which
headline is fake on Fridays no no you've
got to join that inner circle
La Crema
over at dailywire.com Knowles use code
Knowles for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign